Marvel is famous for being very
secretive they obviously their shows are
very popular you are now playing great
Marvel superhero Luke Cage they don't
want anybody to find out know about the
script so I've heard they go to great
lengths to make sure that only you can
read the script that right yeah I mean
they had a few little incidents back in
the past where actors would like half
their scripting it would leave it
accidentally on a bench or something in
a park and then someone would find it I
mean and not someone a marvel like
person would find it because they they
follow us you know that right
they follow us I'm never alone you know
like even now someone in the audience
works for Marvel yeah I'm not sure which
one I'm trying to figure it out but I
think it might might be that guy right
there but somebody here is working for
marbles so if something I do or say
doesn't drive well with what they want
they're there to correct me so after a
while you know they got past that and
they started putting in a computer so if
you want to do something you had to like
put your fingerprint on there you had to
put like a little swab of your saliva
you had to put it inside this little
thing here to send it away I mean that's
what you have to do to get like the
computer to open up and then you leave
it for like 10 seconds it closes again
and you got to do the thing all over
again so it's like this whole thing what
you have to do all these passwords just
to get us your own file so you're
learning your character literally like
three lines at a time literally for a
six month I'm like okay I looked at this
three lines no way okay hold on to that
alright I got that I have to open it
back up again yeah that's pretty much
how it works
my brother Luke collected comic books
and I remembered when Luke Cage came on
the scene it was like I think in
nineteen seventy seventy two yeah yeah
and it was a huge deal he was clearly
overnight the coolest superhero and just
judging on the clip and talking to you I
think this is gonna be pretty amazing
well fingers crossed people still like
it I'm hoping yeah all right well I was
up for that part it was me in him
literally he's not joking he went down
to the wire on that two of us sitting in
the room and they somehow came to the
conclusion it was me yeah
I don't know why they dropped the ball
there
you